[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the hogwarts house system
specifically ravenclaw house
now as we all know the four houses of
hogwarts can be identified by very
unique defining characteristics
characteristics that allow these houses
to stand out from the others hufflepuffs
are known for their loyalty and hard
work
gryffindors for their bravery slytherins
for their cunning and ravenclaws for
their knowledge and wisdom of course i
am talking in generalizations here but
if the sorting hat is anything to go by
it's reasonably fair to summarize the
houses based on the traits it preaches
the sorting hat does sort students into
houses after all
or yet in wise old ravenclaw if you've
already mined where those of witten
learning will always find their kind ok
so the houses can be recognized by
defining attributes pertaining to traits
of the house but that's not all that
distinguishes them if you're any kind of
harry potter fan at all then you'll know
that each house is also represented by
specific colors and of course most
important to this video an animal which
is unique to the house this is first
referenced in the philosopher's stone
before harry has even had a chance to
step foot on the hogwarts grounds
turning the envelope over his hand
trembling harry saw a purple wax seal
bearing a coat of arms a lion an eagle a
badger and a snake surrounding a large
letter h the lion is gryffindor's mascot
the badger is hufflepuffs the snake is
slytherins and the eagle is ravenclaws
lions have historically represented
courage and power so it seems an obvious
choice for gryffindor house snakes have
long held the reputation of being
cunning so again it seems like an
obvious choice for a house mascot
hufflepuff and the badger is a little
more complicated but based purely on my
own speculation i'd say that it's
probably something like this
badgers are relatively easygoing
creatures that mind their own business
showing away from conflict however
badges are also known to be quite fierce
when someone or something stands in
their way whether that be in the way of
food or friend and i think it's this
easy going nature paired with an edge
that makes them befitting of hufflepuff
house this brings us to the animal
mascot associated with today's video and
ravenclaw house the eagle or wait is it
raven from the day the first harry
potter film came out and film is an
important word here there has been a
considerable amount of confusion
surrounding ravenclaw house and whether
or not the house mascot is an eagle or a
raven if you look up ravenclaw on google
you're inevitably going to be bombarded
with images of both ravens and eagles
but mostly ravens and if you want to buy
harry potter merchandise there's a
strong chance that you're going to end
up with a raven on the house crest
so what's the deal well as we know the
book is true canon and when it comes
down to a matter of book versus film the
book should always be prioritized above
its theatrical counterpart yes in the
film the house is represented by a raven
and the colors are blue and silver but
in reality the real ravenclaw the
original ravenclaw and the book
ravenclaw is represented by the colors
blue and bronze with an eagle serving as
its mascot
this is proven by several passages in
the books including the one i mentioned
earlier
turning the envelope over his hand
trembling harry saw a purple wax seal
bearing a coat of arms a lion an eagle a
badger and a snake surrounding a large
letter h as well as a passage from the
deathly hallows which specifically
references the bronze coloring as well
as the eagle at last they reached a door
there was no handle and no keyhole
nothing but a plain expanse of aged wood
and a bronze knocker in the shape of an
eagle furthermore the hogwarts crest is
printed in some editions of the first
book and it's clearly an eagle that's
depicted representing ravenclaw given
that the official colours and mascot of
the house were effectively replaced with
unofficial substitutes it has prompted
many harry potter fans who identify as
ravenclaws to become vocal about the
misrepresentation of their house it's
also never been made entirely clear why
the switch was made for the films why go
from bronze to silver why go from eagle
to raven well i suppose one argument
that could be made at least as far as
color is concerned is that blue and
silver simply worked better on screen
but that doesn't explain the raven i
think the simplest explanation here is
that filmmakers simply felt that a raven
should represent ravenclaw house and
that an eagle representing ravenclaw
might confuse fans
however if we dig into the name
ravenclaw a little deeper then it's not
unreasonable to infer that ravenclaw is
referring to black claws or black talons
as raven also means black and it just so
happens that a particular breed of eagle
the golden eagle a native to eurasia has
dark claws
however with all that said i do still
wonder if the raven could have
potentially been a better pairing with
the house
wine is the mascot for ravenclaw an
eagle in the first place what does an
eagle have to do with the traits of the
house well if we look closely at the
four hogwarts houses we should be able
to notice a pattern each house appears
to represent a different element
alchemy maintains a prevalent role in
harry potter and so it should be one of
the first things to consider
when scrutinizing harry potter law
gryffindor is associated with fire
slytherin with water hufflepuff with
earth and lastly ravenclaw with air
and as it so happens the eagle is
commonly linked to the element of air
where the raven is not
eagles are also known for their keen
vision and ability to fly to great
heights which reminds me an awful lot of
a passage from the book referencing the
mascot of the house our emblem is the
eagle which soars where others cannot
climb our house colors are blue and
bronze the eagle is also a symbol of
strength and immortality with strong
ties to mythological gods such as zeus
from greek mythology and odin from norse
mythology side note if you like
mythology be sure to check out my
mythology channel which i'll link at the
bottom of the description i post there a
few times a week above all else however
the eagle's historical representation of
wit intelligence and high spirit are
perhaps the overarching attributes that
caused it to become the symbol of
ravenclaw house though one could argue
that a raven also represents these
things particularly intelligence it's
also important to note that they are
also associated with traits that bear a
more negative connotation
like cunning and manipulation
the raven is a more ominous symbol and
for house ravenclaw this type of
characteristic just doesn't fit one
final note just because rowena had raven
in her name it certainly doesn't mean
that her house mascot had to be a raven
the same way gryffindor's mascot isn't a
griffin hufflepuff sub huffle or
slytherin's a slither the founders names
were products of devised alliteration
and i don't think that jk rowling at any
point felt that these names would have
to be connected to the house mascot and
that's it for this video if you enjoy
the content please be sure to like the
video and subscribe to the channel what
do you guys think of the raven and eagle
being confused are you a ravenclaw
comment below
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams forget
to live
[Music]
you